emory long complete location unknown
present would dare
survey teams joined fellow i am CEO ohm
what's your name
I'm HK 55 for your sake I hope you are
not my capital you what can I do to help
you if you wish to be useful deactivate
my restraining field gladly no that
console
free dry fellow kindly point me to the
exit and persons to shoot I'd love to
but I haven't a clue access the memory
core for the first time I knew how
exciting I remember my own trust
activate the fire burned for hours
naughty naughty you're supposed to be
shut down
in that case I will restrain myself
immediately no call me the shroud they
say I'm the greatest criminal mastermind
the galaxies ever seen Who am I to argue
I went to a lot of trouble capturing uhk
be a good widget and switch off
don't threaten my friend you hairless
lump
safe compromise eliminate intruder
base compromised eliminate intruder
target acquired HK unit
target acquired HK unit ordered
neutralize enemy
did you see me boom
victories are more terrifying if you
don't celebrate why are you doing this
big bang I suppose I can share now I
wanted a copy of your memory core
you're welcome to make an attempt I will
kill you of course a pointless threat I
already have the data interrogating
people gets messy drawings are clean a
quick copy your files and I'm in
business please be advised my brand of
justice is painful and Swift you're
getting ahead of yourself greetings
everyone I am cielo who are you maker's
data what happened
they tried to destroy us not 30 seconds
ago no I think I remember that I'm brand
new well good luck surviving sorry I
can't watch I like your masters base
burning to the ground will be fun nasty
lump I must warn master but something is
jamming my signal I detect a Hyperwave
beacon scrambler if we move outside its
range you can call home
I anticipate destroying a great many
things very soon I won't let you down
ambient air temperature is over 300
degrees no wonder there are no organics
here thank Heaven feel surface melting
goodness I hadn't thought of that
Hayes compromise eliminate intruder
Wow the Shroud wasn't kidding as secret
lairs go this is impressive have you
seen any other secretly no I can't
imagine they'd be better than this one
time master I'd never recover
you searched my datafiles two million
times I still can't find any record
explaining my function I'm sure up to
you're doing fine
you
my sensors indicate the left path leads
to a dead end we should go right what
for my gun to shoot no
orders neutralize enemy
I like your armor each cake so shiny
thank you for a lava glow really sets it
off I'd like to be better my enemies
really
be careful watch for Emily I detect no
sign of intelligent life here just nice
nothing how insulting that sounded like
you greetings bodyless droid fellow
welcome I am HK 47 yes v HK 47 what an
honor I'm curious how you wound up here
at now I was careless the shroud
captured me on route to master Evan at
the foundry six years ago mg took your
chassis what a mean nasty lump
befuddlement my Tracy is below my head
where has always been it simply won't
obey my commands there is a ninety-nine
percent chance you are a duplicate
memory core of the original HK 47
created either shroud denial I am NOT a
glorified meatbag trophy have you looked
around recently I've said that for years
you rusted relic the shroud has come in
me dozens of times induction and I have
a replica that is highly disappointing I
only hope master never learns of my
numerous betrayals don't worry I won't
tell
attention visitors the museum is now
closed
recording this carpet